but you're against the idea of taxpayer
supported loans going to college right
well look it's a it we hold the note
right so it's whether I'm against it or
not I I get I get a little curious about
it when it gets to a trillion dollars so
if if we're lending money that
ostensibly we don't have to kids who
really have no hope of paying it back in
order to train them for jobs that
clearly don't exist I might suggest that
you know we've gone around the bend a
little bit and our clearly pumping that
extra money into the system allows
colleges to raise their prices I mean of
course know the cost of a degree and
this I do know because I've read it in
several reputable sources has increased
that over 500 times the rate of
inflation since the mid 80s 500 times
the rate of inflation
nothing else comes close not even health
care health care is like 250-260 so this
this thing is an outlier this thing that
the cost of this thing has increased so
exponentially I can't believe it's not
daily headline news